Vaati: This area and what happened here long ago
is what Maria hides behind the Astral Clocktower
This is the Fishing Hamlet
the third and final stage of Bloodborne's DLC
Beneath the surface, off to the left and the right,
is the city of Yharnam
The Nightmare we progressed through, from this perspective at least,
resided beneath the great lake all along
which explains why all the patients in the previous episode
heard the dripping, and the currents, and the rain
I went through the footage actually, because I was curious,
and, just before the clock tower opened,
both hands aligned on one of the many runes that line the edges of the clock
Guess which one it was?
They pointed to a Deep Sea Rune. It reads:
"This transcription of the Great Ones' inhuman voices depicts downreaching currents.
This rune means 'Deep Sea'. Great volumes of water serve as a bulwark guarding sleep,
and an augur of the eldritch Truth. Overcome this hindrance and seek what is yours"
The truths hidden here have to do with the Byrgenwerth scholars who violated this small fishing village long ago
Befuddled Villager: "Byrgenwerth... Byrgenwerth...
Blasphemous murderers... blood-crazed fiends...
Attonement for the wretches... By the wrath of Mother Kos...
Mercy for the poor, wizened child...
Mercy, oh please..."
Vaati: There's a lot in this dialogue
Firstly, this inhabitant of the village had some interaction with the scholars of Byrgenwerth,
the 'wretches' as he calls them. The murderers, the blood-crazed fiends, they did something to a child
and he calls upon the wrath of Mother Kos, who's name should probably be familiar to you, right?
Micolash: "Ahh, Kos, or some say Kosm...
Do you hear our prayers?"
Vaati: Clearly, she's a Great One.
As recommended by a couple of people in the last video
if you come here as a piece of cauliflower then instead the villager says this:
Befuddled Villager: "Curse here, curse there. A curse for he, and she, why care.
A bottomless curse, a bottomless sea, source of all greatness, all things that be.
Listen for the baneful chants. Weep with them, as one in trance.
And weep with us, oh, weep with us..."
Vaati: So what did those of Byrgenwerth do to warrant curses being placed upon them?
It must have been pretty terrible and the accursed brew reads:
"Skull of a local from the violated fishing village. The inside of the skull was forcibly searched for eyes,
as evidenced by the innumerable scratches and indentations. No wonder the skull became stewed in curses"
And this skull partly explains it. It sounds like the scholars of Byrgenwerth came to this little village
and violated the inhabitants in the name of new discoveries.
And it also sounds like the villagers called upon a Great One to curse the scholars.
According to the Moon Rune, the Great Ones are sympathetic in spirit, after all
and based on the way the Byrgenwerth scholars were violating them and searching them for eyes,
clearly the villagers had had some interaction with the Eldritch truth.
So the scholars were cursed and so were their successors, the hunters.
At this point, I went back and I unlocked all the cells we found in episode 1, do you remember those?
They were just past Ludwig.
According to this key,
hunters are held within the underground cells so that things better left unseen and better left unknown
will decay quietly. Within the first few cells, we find this church pick hunter. He drops the church pick
which is a sort of pickaxe crossed with a short sword or a spear type thing
And I also unlocked the door that held this guy who was reciting something
about being a true blade of the Church. According to the wikis, his only purpose is to be killed
and looted for his set which names him as Yamamura the Wanderer, an Eastern warrior
who pursued a beast for honorable revenge and then became a hunter of the league.
The innermost cell belonging to the bell ringer remains locked. For now.
Bell Ringer: "Do you hear this?
Fear the bell's toll.
For only death awaits foolish prying eyes,
and the Church assassins are never far behind."
Vaati: Clearly there's more to discover so now that the stage is set,
let's play our part and get through to the finale
I love how this stage feels like an actual fishing village. They've done a great job with that.
It's a unique location for a level as far as the Soulsborne series goes
and they do so much with such a simple theme.
The fishmen are a dime a dozen
and I like how back stabs are actually a viable technique against them,
unlike most enemies in Bloodborne up until this point.
The fishmen attack in packs and they serve
as the standard enemy but the real threat are the giant fish troll things.
The most scary enemy, in my opinion, is the one that can outrun your player character
and just look at how this thing moves when I turn my back on it.
It scared the shit out of me right there
Approximately 1000 back stabs later, you learn just how difficult these things are
Maybe I should've used those obviously placed fire pots against it
Hmm. A note for next time
Hidden on the cliff face, also, is a path back to the ladder that was in front of the starting lantern
The player who pays attention is more likely to have checked for a hidden path back, which is a nice touch
And it is pretty worth it to look around all the time.
Look at this thing
I noped out of here pretty quick. I didn't really fancy one of those things attacking me on a ladder
And I have to say, again, I really like the way this bit is designed. I only looked around because I started to hear
the Winter Lanterns singing and that's a kind of sound you want to watch out for
and it rewarded me by telling me there's a giant fish troll on the roof
You guys are probably realizing that I really like when games reward the observant player
I've probably said that a lot of times by now
So this next thing that happened probably happened to all of you guys too, right?
You start fighting one of the fish trolls and you know, you convince yourself
that other one on the roof isn't gonna come attack me. That's not gonna happen
And then you're about to win and you're like, hang on, what's that noise?
Godammit. One of these things was tough enough but two?
I ran away and I got up the ladder just in time and I was gonna plan my next attack
And then I fell in.
Don't worry, I survived until I got out and then I was like
'I know, I'll drop those rope Molotov cocktails behind me. They can fall down ladders, right?'
Uhh, no. Turns out they can't
And then I fell in again (Seriously Vaati?)
And at this point, I just made plunging attacks a part of my strategy
It didn't work, really...
Eventually I just 'got gud' and I realized, to my surprise, that one of them had dropped a weapon
It was the Rakuyo which is Maria's weapon
It reads: "Hunter weapon wielded by Lady Maria of the Astral Clocktower
A trick sword originating in the same country as the Cainhurst Chikage, only this sword feeds not off blood,
but instead demands great dexterity. Lady Maria was fond of this aspect of the Rakuyo,
as she frowned upon blood blades, being a distant relative of the queen.
One day, she abandoned her beloved Rakuyo, casting it into a dark well, when she could stomach it no longer."
What a neat little story.
Maria must have eventually given into her desire for blood
as she certainly uses blood and self-sacrifice in her boss fight.
How curious that she's related to Queen Annalise, as well
I've got some theories on this but it'll have to wait for Prepare to Cry
By the end of the playthrough, the Rakuyo becomes my main weapon
This is a skill build after all, using the Blades of Mercy, the Burial Blade
and not to mention this character actually looks just like Maria, right?
I modeled this character after the Doll ages ago so yeah, who would've thought that would pay off?
It's cool to have a weapon that you can call your own, you know?
I've been searching for one for a while and mine is the Rakuyo.
What's yours? You should let me know!
In a hut further down, we find a lantern and lying on the ground,
dying next to that lantern is Simon, the Bowblade Hunter
Simon: "...Oh, you, I'm afraid, I've made a botch of things...
...I can hear the bell, now...
...The beast-hide assassin, he's after me...
...Again and again...
...It never ends... (gasp)
...Please, I need you to do something...
...This village is the true secret. Testament to the old sins...
...It feeds this Hunter's Nightmare...
...Please, bring to an end the horror...
...So our forefathers sinned?
...We hunters cannot bear their weight forever...
...It isn't fair, it just isn't fair..."
(last breath)
Vaati: Simon was one of the last sane hunters in the Nightmare
He pushed us to go deeper and deeper into it and with Maria gone,
he seems like he decided to come forward himself and fight a little bit farther
However, there is another hunter here, other than Simon
Someone who doesn't want anyone discovering what lies at the end of the Nightmare
Brador, the Church Assassin
The weapon he uses is the Bloodletter "which assumes it's true and terrifying form
after it draws upon blood from the inner reaches of one's body and soul"
This is what it reads.
This was the only effective method of expelling tainted blood
or so Brador, isolated in his cell, continued to believe
Brador: "Well, well, look who's here.
Welcome to my quarters. I've never entertained a guest before.
Are you going to kill me?
After all you've done, kill me, as if to right your wrongs?
(laughter)
You get his weapon if you kill him but I kept Brador alive here because I wasn't sure if there was more to him
and sure enough, he does invade you a total of 4 times throughout the rest of the stage.
Once outside his cell, once on a bridge, once in ambush when you pick up an item down below
and once in a cave.
Each time he drops a different piece of his attire.
The clothing has it's own story as well.
Turns out, Brador was a Church assassin who wore the beast-hide of his former compatriots.
The Church gave him a bell that he could ring to hunt people down and stop people discovering their secrets
And we'll talk more about him later but moving on...
In the next section, I spied one of those mollusc things clinging to a post
and I was like 'yeah, I'm not gonna let myself get ambushed by that thing'
I still remembered how one of them fell on me in an earlier level
and then I was like worried about looking upwards and
hundreds of them crawled out of shells and ambushed me and I felt pretty stupid
But seriously, do you remember that first one that fell out of the sky in episode 1?
It makes sense now, doesn't it? All along there was this world above us, we just didn't have the insight to see it
And how this one fell out of the Nightmare itself is beyond me
But it's a cool concept to think that all of these Nightmares are layered.
It makes me think about the ship masts all over the ocean as we progress
Think about it. You've actually seen these ship masts before
You can actually see them in the Nightmare Frontier,
suggesting that there's water down there, hidden in the fog
Or perhaps that the Nightmare Frontier is even connected to this Nightmare but is even higher up
After all, in the first stage of the DLC, there's an Amygdala corpse as well
Perhaps it fell out of the Nightmare frontier as well
This is really speculation but interesting to think about
To quote the Cosmic Eye Watcher Badge:
"Here we stand, feet planted in the earth,
but might the cosmos be very near us, only just above our heads?"
All of the Nightmare realms are really high up and they all have Great Ones residing at some of their highest points
Land masses float in the Nightmare frontier with Mergo in his loft in the tallest tower
The Hunter's Dream is nestled amongst these archtree looking things in the clouds
with the Moon Presence descending from above
And the Hunter's Nightmare is within a great ocean, below a grand lake of mud
and on the beach of said lake is the washed up corpse of a Great One that was discovered long ago
(sobbing)
Born from this corpse is the Orphan of Kos
How curious that the Orphan's mother wasn't alive for the birth
It reminds me of how the Moon Presence must die for us to be born as a Great One as well
This is probably one of the hardest bosses in Bloodborne
The Orphan is insanely quick, he has a hugely varied move set and he even has a second phase where he
evolves into a butterfly looking thing
The neat little observations in this fight are that he's fighting you with the placenta that trailed out with him
when he was born and also that Mother Kos herself has a face
Turns out she's somewhat humanoid in form just like he is
And I actually can't help myself,
I start talking about gameplay and then I get pulled back to talking about the lore again
I kind of figure that you guys are realizing how good the gameplay has been for the most part in this level
It's been an amazing stage but let's just roll with it, let's just talk about the story
while I show you some of my failed fights against this guy
Specifically, let's talk about why our character is here, why we're doing all of this
We do have most of the items and dialogue now, after all
In the dialogue at the start, we learned that the Byrgenwerth scholars stumbled upon this fishing village
and that they did some pretty terrible things
Not only did they violate the villagers themselves, as mentioned in the accursed brew description
But they must have also stumbled upon the Great One Kos or her corpse at least which washed up on the shore
because they managed to get themselves cursed
The man at the start of the village and even the woman speaking as you get pulled into the DLC, remember her?
Both of them plead for curses to be placed upon the fiends, upon their children and their children's children,
on man and woman alike.
A bottomless curse, a curse forever true
And the Great Ones do have the power to curse people. According to the Defiled Chalice,
which is an item a lot of us probably have forgotten about, curses are, and I quote:
"caused by inciting the anger of the Great Ones"
Additionally, according to the Moon Rune:
as I've mentioned, the Great Ones are sympathetic in spirit
So it's not crazy to think that a Great One may have listened to the inhabitants of the fishing village
as they pleaded for the Byrgenwerth scholars to be cursed in return for violating their village
The curse means that the Byrgenwerth scholars and, eventually, their successors the hunters
would be drawn into a Hunter's Nightmare upon death.
And it's a pretty perfect curse when you think about it
It's like the Great One is saying 'oh, you like hunting so much?
Well live here forever and hunt for all eternity then'.
Simon tells us that the village is the source of the sin
and implies that we can bring an end to the curse here. So we do what a hunter does best. We hunt.
Voice: "...Ahh, sweet child of Kos, returned to the ocean...
A bottomless curse, a bottomless sea. Accepting of all that there is and can be."
Vaati: When you get back to the Hunter's Dream, the Doll will tell you that both she and Gerhman
sense that they've somehow been freed from their shackles
This happens to the Doll and Gerhman when you kill Maria and the Orphan respectively.
I'm starting to understand how they're connected to these creatures but
it is still really weird that they can sense their counterparts in the Nightmare
I'm still trying to figure it out. Hell, I personally haven't even got this dialogue yet because the Doll
doesn't give you the dialogue if the dream is on fire, which is annoying
I'll have to play through again so I can show it to you
But... so much to talk about here. There's a million other things I want to talk to you guys about
There's even another boss in this DLC that I don't have time to include
But mostly I really wanna talk to you guys about the lore, still
This DLC revealed a ton about the timeline, it reveals a lot about how Nightmare realms work
and it's raised even more questions that I myself haven't answered
It's expanded the stories of Gerhman, of Micolash, of Laurence and the Doll
and all of those videos will be coming soon, I promise
I could rush the lore stuff out for views but I do want to do it properly so
thank you for subscribing and waiting and I reckon it's best to do it right the first time.
I also have to thank you guys for supporting this three part series so well
I didn't think a playthrough would go down so amazingly but it did and I really appreciate all the likes and views
and the thousands and thousands of comments.
I love telling stories and I enjoyed telling my own story about my playthrough and my observations
and it was really cool to read yours in the comments as well. You guys rock. Let's do it again sometime
And also, lastly, a special thanks to all the patrons that support me over on Patreon
You've made it possible for me to do this full time now and you're incredible and thank you for changing my life
I'll see you in the next one. Cheers guys